fallout 4 is a dense and engrossing RPG
set in a post nuclear apocalypse version
of Boston it's unusual to find yourself
hunted by oafish mutants while you
struggle with wounded limbs radiation
poisoning or an unfortunate lack of ammo
it's wonderfully tense moments like this
that make fallout for such an engaging
and intoxicating experience you grow
very familiar with fats the system you
use to plot every pull of the trigger
the mix of utility and strategy that it
presents is encouraging and it's a far
more enjoyable and effective tool than
real-time shooting fallout 4 is an
involving RPG with a wealth of stories
to explore and activities to engage in
but it's also an old looking game you
immediately notice poor character models
muddy textures and a bevy of glitches
when fallout 4 shows it's wrinkles it
feels like a direct extension of fallout
3 rather than a sequel years in the
making however the more time you spend
with the game the less you care when
you're enraptured with characters
struggling with difficult decisions and
engaged in combat you no longer care
that something could look better or be
more organized fallout 4 is a strong
argument for substance over style and
it's a remarkable open-world RPG
you